I begin by stressing the amazing
achievements of humankind in the last
century
and the unprecedented position that we
find ourselves in today
for thousands of years the three biggest
problems of humankind have been famine
plague and War
and humans have prayed to every
conceivable God an angel and Saint to
help them and it didn't work and they
tried all kinds of political systems and
economic models and this didn't work
either and then over the last century or
so
um thanks largely to human Ingenuity and
to Scientific development we have
managed to reign in to gain control of
famine plague and War there are still of
course huge problems in the world there
is still violence there is still disease
but these have become from
uncontrollable forces of nature into
something that we know better and better
how to prevent and overcome today in the
world more people die from eating too
much than from eating too little for the
first time in history I think the last
uh data from the World Health
Organization says that about 3 million
people die each year from obesity and
related diseases compared to one million
people that die from starvation and
malnutrition
at the same time for the first time in
history more people die from old age
than from infectious diseases
and also for the first time in history
more people commit suicide each year
than the total number of Death From War
crime and terrorism put together which
is very good news
um not the suicide bit possible no but
the fact that it's affected yes yes it's
going down it's not that suicide that
went up it's that death from violence
have gone down
um today let's say for the people here
in this room I think it's safe to say
that McDonald's and Coca-Cola pose a far
greater threat to your life than
al-Qaeda in the Islamic State
the chance that you
the chance that you will die from eating
too much at McDonald's is about A
Thousand Times Higher and this is not an
exaggeration this is statistics it's
about a thousand times higher than the
chance you'll be killed by some Islamic
State terrorism attack
so we are gaining the ability to bring
under our control
these uh huge problems again there are
still problems of course but most of
them when it comes to famine plague and
War are the result of human politics and
human incompetence not of human
ignorance if you again take famine
there are no longer any natural famines
in the world only political famines if
somebody if a human being today on Earth
dies because they don't have enough to
eat in Syria or in North Korea or in
Somalia it's not because of natural
causes it's because some political
leader or government or ideology wants
them to starve to death so this is a new
phase in the history of the world we
have managed without any Divine help to
bring these three problems under our
control
and then the next question that the book
homodeeos asks is what next
so if we have solved or we are in the
process of solving these problems what
will we do with ourselves in the next
Century or two
and the book suggests that the next big
projects of humankind will be to
overcome old age and death
to find the keys the secret to happiness
and to basically upgrade humans into
Gods this is why the title homodels God
man
and I don't mean it as a kind of
literary metaphor
a minute in as in in the literal sense
that
for thousands of years humans have
imagined gods in a particular way they
ascribed particular abilities and
qualities to gods and we are here in a
church and the walls are full of these
descriptions of what God can do
and we are now seriously in the business
of acquiring these traditional Divine
abilities and qualities to ourselves
uh whether it's trying to overcome death
and gain immortality or whether it's
gaining the ability to create and design
life according to our wishes in the
Bible in the Book of Genesis basically
the first thing God does is to create
animals and plants and humans according
to his wishes we are now trying to gain
this Divine ability to ourselves it's
very likely that in the 21st century the
main product the most important products
of the human economy will no longer be
just vehicles and textiles and food and
weapons the main products will be bodies
and brains and Minds and in a way we are
even reaching beyond what ancient
religions ascribed to to the Gods
because the Gods like Jehovah in the
Bible they could create only organic
beings if you look if you're a
creationist and you look at the world so
all these animals all these plants God
created them and they are all organic
now humans are trying to do better than
that we will not just gain the ability
to create these organic beings that's
been around for 4 billion years we are
in the process of learning how to create
the fire the first inorganic entities
inorganic beings uh like artificial
intelligence that ever existed